- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up with
the latest UCTV programs.
- I'm Stanley Brandes.
I'm a member of the
Department of Anthropology
here at Cal and the chair
of the Foerster Lecturers Committee.
Along with the graduate council,
we are pleased to present
today, Tanya Luhrmann,
this year's speaker in our lecture series.
As a condition of this
bequest, the Foerster bequest,
we're obligated to tell
you how the endowment
supporting the Foerster
lectures on the immortality
of the soul came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to
the history of California
and the Bay Area.
In 1928, Ms. Edith Swaybrook established
the Foerster Lectureship
to honor the memory
of Agnes A. Foerster and
Constantine E. A. Foerster.
Edith was a public school
teacher in San Francisco
for many years and the
teaching profession was,
to her, an opportunity
to develop true knowledge
and love of the spiritual values of life
in the young minds entrusted to her care.
Edith's beloved sister, Agnes A. Foerster,
shared her high ideals and hopes,
as did Agnes' husband,
Constantine E. A. Foerster.
A lawyer by profession, Foerster was a man
of high intellectual achievements
and rare personal charm.
Although he passed away at the age of 37,
he had achieved an enviable
place at the San Francisco Bar
and was considered one of its
most highly-respected members.
For several years prior to his death,
Foerster was a law partner
of Alexander F. Morrison,
one of the most prominent
of San Francisco attorneys,
for whom our Morrison
Memorial Library is named.
In her last days, Ms.
Edith Swaybrook expressed
her deep and abiding
interest in spiritual life
by creating this lecture series on
the Imortality of the Soul,
or similar spiritual topics.
She believed that through the medium
of a great university and the
words of scholarly lecturers,
she might bring new
light upon a topic that
has interested the world for centuries.
Thank you, Edith Swaybrook.
(audience applauding)
And now, about our distinguished lecturer.
Tanya Luhrmann is a very well-known
and influential anthropologist.
Her work focuses on the ways that objects
without material presence
come to seem real to people,
and how ideas about the mind
affect mental experience.
Her previous studies
have analyzed phenomena
such as witchcraft,
charismatic Christians,
and psychiatrists.
Her wildly-acclaimed
third book, Of Two Minds,
offered an ethnographic study
of the American Psychiatric Community
and examined how disciplinary
and ideological pressures
that accompany psychiatric training
shaped the experiences of psychiatrists
and patients alike.
Of Two Minds was awarded
the Victor Turner Prize
for Ethnographic Writing,
and the Boyer Prize
for Psychological Anthropology.
In her most recent book,
When God Talks Back,
Luhrmann looks at the way
in which practitioners
within American Evangelical
Christian communities
come to experience God
as a being with whom
they can engage in direct
communication through acts
of prayer and visualizations.
When God Talks Back was
named both a New York Times
Notable Book, and a Kirkus
Reviews Book of the Year.
Tanya Luhrmann is Watkins
University professor
in the Stanford Anthropology Department.
She earned her BA in
Folklore and Mythology
at Harvard University in 1981 and her PhD
in social anthropology
at Cambridge University
in 1986.
She previously taught
at the University of California San Diego
and the University of Chicago
before joining the anthropology faculty
of Stanford University in 2007.
She is a recipient of
fellowships and grants
from the Guggenheim Foundation,
the Templeton Foundation,
the National Institute of Health,
the National Science Foundation,
and she's been elected
to the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
Many of you might also
know her through her,
the past several years,
she's been an occasional
op-ed contributor to the
pages of the New York Times,
where most of her work,
that I've read anyway,
has dealt with the Evangelical
Christian experience.
The title of today's talk is
The Quest for Heaven is Local.
How spiritual experience
is shaped by social life.
Please join me in
welcoming Tanya Luhrmann.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So this is great.
I'm going to present some new work to you.
And, thank you, for
joining me on this journey
of beginning to understand what,
trying to make sense of the material
that I'm coming to know.
Alright, I'll begin with my usual caveat
which is that I'm going to talk about God.
But nothing that I say is an argument
for or against God's real reality.
What puzzles me is that God is invisible.
And so, the question
is, how do people come
to feel confident of God's existence.
About 10 years, I set out to understand
the major shift in American spirituality
since 1965, towards a
more direct, immediate,
and personal experience of God.
Arguably, a quarter of all Americans
are involved in this kind of renewalist
Christian spirituality.
And I find myself doing research in
a Vineyard Christian Fellowship.
So there are about 600 of these churches
in the country and thousands
of more that are like them.
These are sometimes called
new paradigm Protestant
Christian churches.
They combine a Conservative
social ideology
with a Liberal social style.
They're more likely to meet
in gyms than in churches.
They're likely to use a rock
band rather than a choir.
They are Evangelical, by
which people typically mean
that they see a personal
relationship with Jesus
as the only route to personal salvation.
And they treat the Bible as literally true
or near-literally true.
True in all that it informs.
So the age of the earth,
maybe that's not so important.
The miracles described in the Gospels
really took place.
This is the church where I spent time
as an anthropologist for two years,
over two years, really, in Chicago.
This is on a summer
morning along the lake.
I went to Sunday morning gatherings.
I was a member of a house group for a year
where we met weekly to pray
and to talk and to read
the Bible.
I hung out with people.
I had coffee with people.
I interviewed people.
I went to all kinds of
regional, national conferences
and events.
And then, I moved to California,
here to the South Bay,
and did it all over again
with another Vineyard church.
So let me tell you a little bit about
the God that I saw in this church.
This is a God who's deeply human.
God is high and mighty and distant,
but also a person among people.
He will hang out with you.
He will chat with you.
He's also deeply supernatural.
So as you hang out with God,
He can intervene in the things,
the little things that you
talk to a friend about.
Like, getting a good haircut,
or where you want to go on your vacation,
or, you know, the argument
you had with your spouse
last night.
He cares about all that stuff and He
can make a difference in your life.
To give you a feel of the way that people
talk about this God,
this is a book by, and I'm quoting here
from a book by Dallas
Willard who's sort of
an Evangelical's intellectual.
And he says, "God's
face-to-face conversations
"with Moses are the normal human life
"God intended for us."
Which is really quite a claim.
This next quotation comes from my favorite
ethnographic artifact, Bruce
and Stan's Pocket Guide
to Talking with God.
And Bruce and Stan tells us,
"It's really important to understand
"that God is not an impersonal force.
"Even though He's invisible,
"God is personal and He
has all the characteristics
"of a person.
"He knows, He hears, He
feels, and He speaks."
You can understand these
engagements with God,
the prayer practices
as imaginal dialogues.
This is a term that Mary Watkins uses
to describe a set of conversations
that we have.
She says, "We may find ourselves speaking
"with our reflection in the mirror,
"with a photograph of someone we miss,
"with a figure from a dream or a movie,
"with our dog.
"And even when we're outwardly silent,
"with the ebb and flow of our thoughts,
"we talk with critics, with our mothers,
"our gods, our consciences."
So these are ordinary human events.
You have these inner voice conversations
in your mind.
Someone like Mary Watkins uses the word,
imaginal, because she's
pointing out that we use
our imagination, but the
person having the conversation
does not necessarily
experience the conversation
as imaginary.
And in a church like this,
people are really encouraged to pray
with these imaginary dialogues,
and to experience themselves as talking
informally to God about
whatever matters to them,
the little ordinary things in your life.
And to experience God
as talking back to you
about those experiences.
In these churches, God
is also a substance,
a force that comes into
your life in the form
of the Holy Spirit.
So the Holy Spirit may
make you feel electric,
may make your skin tingle,
you may feel goosebumps.
The Holy Spirit can move
through a circle of people
and lead to the healing of
the person in the center
of the prayer circle.
The Holy Spirit can sweep down the aisle
and knock somebody over.
And the Holy Spirit can twist your tongue
so you speak with a language-like sound
that's not actually a language
but is understood to be a language
that God can understand
and the Devil cannot.
This is what I was interested
in as an anthropologist.
The task for a congregant in this church
is to experience the imaginal dialogue
as not merely imaginary but as somehow
rooted in the world outside the head
as being, in some part, real in the world.
The person in the church like this
must also learn to experience
God's immaterial presence
to some extent in a material way.
More important, to experience
the imaginal dialogue,
but there's also this
yearning to feel this sense
of God's presence in an empirical way.
I knew that this involved training.
Because when I come out of these churches,
people would sometimes
arrive as a new member
of the congregation
and say something like,
"Please, so-and-so, would
you pray to God for me
"because I know that God talks to you,
"but Got doesn't talk to me."
And six to nine months
into their experience
of the church, they
would formulate sentences
like, "I recognize God's
voice the way I recognize
"my mom's voice on the phone."
So the book that I wrote
basically did three...
I'm going to say it did three things.
First of all, I could see
the people, in order to learn
to experience God is
interacting with them.
People had to learn to
interpret their thoughts
and to make sense of
their mental experience
in many ways.
And people had to ask the question,
"Was that God speaking to me?"
And they would pick out thoughts
that they might have
attributed to themselves,
but that they learned to
experience and understand
as not their own thoughts
but God speaking to them.
In other words, they thought that thought
was not self-authored.
It was other-authored.
People would do this by identifying
a thought that was louder
than other thoughts.
It would sort of spontaneously
pop into their mind.
It took them by surprise.
And then, they were
made to ask themselves,
and the church would invite them to ask
these kinds of question,
"Is this consistent with the scriptures?
"Is this the kind of
thing that God would say?"
And then, how did you feel
when you had that thought?
Did you feel as if it gave you peace?
Did you feel good?
Because if a loving God talks to you,
you should feel pretty good about that.
And they would ask people to see if they
could confirm that that
was what God was saying
by other means.
I also described in this book
what I called inner sense cultivation.
And I made the argument that
the prayer practice people use
when they're really
intensely trying to use
their imagination to
allow God to come alive,
had psychological effects
on their mental experience.
So when people began to pray like this
and they talked informally to God,
and they tried to imagine
that God was present.
And they would throw
themselves into the scriptures
so that when they tried to
understand Blind Bartimaeus,
they tried to see him as he
sat by the side of the road.
They tried to imagine
the color of his cloak
and what it was like when He flung it away
to follow Jesus.
They really wanted to see
it as if they were there.
And I argued in this book,
using some experimental work,
I've got a foot in psychology, as well,
that this actually did change something
about the quality of
your mental experience.
It made your mental
world, inner mental world,
come alive, feel more real,
feel more external to you.
I also saw in this church a striking use
of imagination.
So congregants in churches like this
are invited to have a
cup of coffee with God,
to go for a walk with God,
to have a beer with God,
to go on a date with God.
People would talk about cuddling
with God on a park bench.
There's a lot of, you know, C. S. Lewis
is really important in churches like this,
and God is the big fluffy lion, Aslan,
as a very important imaginative vehicle
for representing the experience of God.
People value spiritual experience.
All these things were important.
One of the things they
did was that the coming
to use your imagination to experience God,
it enabled God to feel real to you.
It also enabled these
Americans to hold God
in a special complicated way,
because if you are imagining
that God is walking
by your side, you know that's God,
but you also know that, to some extent,
you're imagining that this is God.
And so, it becomes cognitively
and epistemologically,
really complicated and sophisticated.
And I thought it kind of
helped these Americans
to manage their own
complicated views about living
in a secular society, in a
world in which many other people
had different views about
God, didn't think that God
existed at all.
And so, if you make God really,
really imaginatively present
you get your God, but you
also learn to hold your God
in a way that is somewhere
between the material
and the immaterial, available to you,
but also marked in
different kinds of ways.
So all that seemed to me
to reflect a particular
and local theory of mine.
Now, we're getting into
that larger project
that I'm going to describe today.
It seemed to me that, as
these Americans talked
to me of God, one of
the things that I heard
was a common American
experience that the mind
is bounded, private.
That there is a wall between your mind
and the world.
It was hard for these Americans to learn
to come to terms with the idea that God
was speaking back to them in their mind.
It took them time to adopt the idea
that there's this external being talking
in their mind.
These Americans also seemed to me
to exemplify an American tendency
to treat feeling as
really, really important.
We live in a world in which
sadness can make you sick.
It justifies you going to the doctor.
It justifies you staying home from work.
We treat our internal experience
as worthy of attention
and, in fact, many of these Americans
that I saw in the Vineyard church,
they would talk to God
about their feelings.
What they wanted to know,
when they talked to God
about a fight with their spouse,
is why they felt so riled up,
and what they were going to do about it,
and how God could help
them feel a little bit
more comfortable.
It's also clear that
there's a complicated story
about realness, that when
people use their imagination
to experience God, they
took their imagination
to be important.
And, in fact, we spent an enormous amount
of time cultivating
imagination in the lives
of our children.
But imagination is not real to Americans.
It's mere imagination.
The stuff in your head
kind of comes and goes.
It's flimsy.
It's not of the world in the same way that
the table and chair is part of the world.
So I decided to find
out what the experience
of God was like in a place in which people
felt very differently about their minds.
And so, the project that I now embarked on
is the project to compare
the way people experience
invisible others in new
charismatic Evangelical churches,
and also folks who struggle
with psychotic illness
and hear voices.
But I don't talk about that in this talk.
I'm looking at churches in
Accra, Ghana, West Africa,
in Chennai, India, and in the
Bay Area, obviously, here.
And the question that I'm asking,
if I see differences in
the experience of God,
does that have anything
to do with different ways
in which the mind is real for people?
There are different ways
in which people understand
the experience of the mind.
The specific questions
I'm going to ask today
are how do congregants in, actually,
two culturally-different but
theologically-similar settings
represent the aim and
experience of imaginal dialogue
in prayer?
What specific spiritual
experiences do congregants
in these different settings
recognize, elaborate,
and report, and do any
of these differences
that I find reflect differences in local
theories of mind, different
ideas about the mind?
And so, I'm going to talk to
you now about my experience
of going off to Accra, and what
I find when I talk to people
in the new charismatic churches there,
of which there of many,
many such churches.
70% of Accra is Christian.
About half of that population
belongs to these churches
that, in many ways, are very much like
the American churches.
They are very recognizable.
So these are big new buildings.
They have thousands of people
in their congregations.
They have tons of
international connections.
They're streaming media
all over the place.
There are billboards everywhere.
These churches become
a kind of social life
for the middle class.
They provide medical
treatment and social events,
and there's a hair salon,
and you can do banking.
You can live your entire
life, if you'd like,
within the confines of
these huge churches.
And everybody speaks english.
Which means, basically,
that, for most people,
this is a venue for the middle class.
And sometimes they're understood as places
where the middle class will come
and meet each other.
It's a good way for a man to meet a woman.
They are very much like
the new charismatic
Evangelical church that
I studied, the Vineyard.
Their theology presents to you
with a personal relationship
with a God who's going to talk back.
This God, people will tell you,
is unconditionally loving.
So it turns out it's a
little bit more complicated
than that, but that's
what people will tell you.
People will tell you that this God
is supernaturally efficacious,
and He deals with their
particular concerns.
With their own ill health.
He gives them stuff.
He's concerned with you
personal experience.
People dress casually for
middle-class Africans in Accra.
These are what the British would call
happy-clappy churches.
Everybody's cheering,
and dancing, and singing,
and speaking in prophecy.
It's fun to go to these churches.
And these are churches
that are chocked full
of American books on
Evangelical Christianity.
You walk into the
bookstores and down one wall
there are all the American books
on Evangelical Christianity
that I come across in this
culture and are sitting
on my bookshelf.
By American authors.
And down the other wall are
all the other books in English
by African authors about the same topics.
If you just look at the church,
it looks like there's
a lot that's similar.
This is not a full ethnographic
study that I'm doing.
I'm trying to do a comparative study
in which I look at three
different settings.
So I now can spend four years in Accra,
and four years in Chennai and, so far,
this is kind of the package
of data that I've collected.
But what I want to talk to you about today
are my interviews with pastoral students
at a school attached to
one of the big churches.
So these are lovely young people.
They're a lot like the people that I saw
in the Chicago Vineyard.
Many of the folks that I spent time with
in the Chicago Vineyard,
there are eight Vineyards in Chicago...
The people I spent time with were mostly
in their middle 20s.
A lot of them went off
to do pastoral work.
They took their Christianity
very, very seriously.
These 15 students that I spent time with
in a recent trip to Accra all intend
to be pastors or to work in some way
in the church.
They are in their middle 20s.
Their schooling had been
conducted entirely in English.
Some of them prayed in English.
They were immersed in the
thinking of this church.
I knew that they...
And it was very Vineyard-like.
They'd taken a class, actually,
on how to experience God
as talking back to you
in your mind.
And they were quite happy to explain to me
all about this class
and how it enabled them
to experience God intimately.
This is the interview that I,
the structure of the
interview that I did with them
and, of course, these are loose
semi-structured interviews.
But with each of these young people,
I asked them about the way
they experienced prayer.
I asked them how they
prayed and I asked them,
in effect, to whom do they pray.
How do they understand God?
How do they understand the
way that God heard them speak?
How do they understand the interaction?
And then, I asked them a
whole set of other questions
about classic spiritual experiences.
So these we know to be phenomena,
psychological phenomena
in the world.
We know that people hear
audible voices periodically.
And we know that people
sometimes have visual experiences
as if they're seeing it with their eyes.
We know that there's some, you don't have
to understand this, but there's some sense
that some other person is
near, tangibly present,
as if they're sitting right next to you.
We know that people
have had that experience
with a non-God Person.
You would see people shake in
church, weep uncontrollably
when they were experiencing
God, or shake...
You know, they'd become all
weak and they'd fall over
or they'd act as if a thunderbolt
had gone through them,
or a bolt of lighting.
You could see people do that.
We know that there are
out of body experiences.
You can generate them in the lab.
I'll talk a little bit more about those.
And we know that there are these phenomena
in which people wake
up and they can't move.
They have an experience
of sleep paralysis.
And you might imagine this is kind
of the straw dogs argument
that I'm arguing against.
You might imagine that these
experiences of the body,
they're a result of kind of a God spot,
and they happen to people, more or less,
in the same way, more or less,
everywhere in the world.
And I was curious to know
whether that was really true.
So let me first tell
you about the experience
that I heard from these
students about talking
to God in their minds, and
having these imaginal dialogues
in which they're talking
to God and they're waiting
for God to talk back.
So, in many ways, if
you've read only the first
10 minutes of my interview,
or you were with me
for my first 10 minutes, these
young people sound exactly
like congregants in the Vineyard.
They tell me that God
is their best friend.
They tell me that they can
talk to Him about anything.
I mean, they talk to Him about dinner.
They talk to Him about their dates.
They talk to Him...
They talk to Him about everything.
They say that God will talk back.
They also say that God
loves them unconditionally.
And they're very clear
when I ask them this.
They absolutely, God loves us without end.
He just loves us the way that we are.
And we have to do stuff, too.
But God just loves us.
They also described discernment
in remarkably similar ways.
So a thought will pop into your mind.
In order to qualify as a
good candidate for something
that God may have said to you,
you've to make sure that it's consistent
with Scripture, the kind of
thing that God might say,
and you've got to feel good
when God is speaking to you
because God is good.
So you should feel a sense of peace.
It gets a little more
complicated than that
if God is telling you not to do something.
But, basically, God is your
friend and God loves you.
And so, you should feel good.
I actually think, this
is kind of a tangent,
but there's something...
Universal is a strong
word to use in an audience
that might not include anthropologists.
But I think there's a
kind of topography of mind
in which there's thing kind of a continuum
of thought phenomena which
are better candidates
for being non-self-authored
thoughts than others.
Dreams, we know, are good
candidates for not coming
from yourself but from
coming from some other source
around the world.
And I think this sense
that, when a thought pops
into your mind, or it's
spontaneous, or it's loud,
I think we will find
that that is very common
around the world as being a candidate
for a non-self-authored thought.
But in any event, this
is they way they talked.
And it was very clearly
that people were doing
imaginal dialogues.
So this is the guy in Accra
who was most comfortable
with imaginal dialogues.
He says, "So I'm lying on my
bed and then I start talking
"to Him.
"It's awesome.
"I can talk to God like I'm talking to you
"and, as you are responding,
even though I don't
"hear your voice, it comes.
"It follows a train.
"A train of conversation,
what you're talking about.
"So, like, I tried to
find out if it's true."
So here, he's trying to do discernment.
"I'll ask a question, and
then God will point me
"to a scripture I've never thought about.
"So he leads me to this
scripture I've not thought about,
"I wasn't thinking about a scripture,
"it wasn't in my mind."
It pops into his mind.
"I go, and the scripture
answers what I was asking."
Meaning it's really God.
"I was just lying on my
bed and I was laughing
"and I heard everything.
And then, I really try to make sure
that it's a back and forth experience.
He's very clear, it is.
So here's his counterpart
in the Chicago Vineyard.
She's talking to me about talking to God.
"I would go get some food,
go out and sit by the lake
"and eat my food and just, God and I would
"have conversations about
I like to say His children.
"Like, if we were dating
and He had children
"and I didn't, I'd want
to know how his children
"were doing.
"And so, you know, I'd ask
him how's such and such
"going with Drew?
"How's such and such going with Christy?
"You know, those sorts of things.
"I really, really hope that you saving up
"for their college tuition kind of idea,
"because, you know, I really
hope you're doing that
"in their lives.
"And then, you know, we'd
go out to this relationship
"with me as his child...",
and then, she talks of Him.
So those are both clearly
imaginal dialogues
and, in ways, they're very
similar to each other.
But, also, they're quite different.
And it seemed to me that the differences
between the two of those
echoed the differences
I found between the Vineyard
congregants, in general,
and the Accra, and the Daniel
Institute pastoral students,
in general.
In general, in Accra, the
back and forth dialogue
was less playful.
It was, literally, less back and forth.
God would talk less frequently.
He would less people modeled...
Less, like, well, I want to the movies.
I want to talk to you about the kids.
How is Christy doing?
Okay, you tell me how Christy's doing.
They didn't really talk like that.
God seemed more distant in some sense.
The sense of hierarchy and authority
was more starkly modeled.
Now, that was very clear in the Vineyard.
With the Vineyard congregants,
the mightiness of God seemed to coexist
with this intimate buddy-buddy-ness.
That was less true in Accra.
And no one ever pretended
to experience in order to...
Nobody ever pretended that God was present
in order to experience as real.
One of the things that C. S. Lewis
does in Mere Christianity,
which is one of his best,
most widely-read books
about Christianity.
Widely read by Evangelical Christian.
He says, "Pretend in order
to experience as real."
I never heard that sentiment
expressed in Accra.
Instead, when people
talked about imagination,
they were much more pragmatic.
So this man says to me,
"What you see is what you get.
"What you see yourself do
is what you can achieve.
"If you can imagine,
"what you imagine is what you become."
And there's a sense that
imagination is very important.
Because you can imagine
yourself as a better
and more-successful person.
And there's a line in the Proverbs,
"As a man thinketh in
his heart, so is he."
I heard that from, I'm going to guess,
two-thirds of my Accra pastoral
students at some point.
It just courses through my interviews
with pastors and with other people.
I never heard it expressed in America.
Doesn't mean it's not important.
I was just struck by the
sense that the way you think,
it really is important.
It wasn't, the mind is
not this ephemeral fluff,
as it's more represented in this country.
So it seemed to me that imagination
was not about fostering creativity.
It was about who you wanted to be
in the world.
It was also true that, in general,
the goal of prayer in Accra
was much more pragmatic.
People talked about money.
They talked about the
health of their family.
Americans talked about feelings.
And just to give you a
feel of these differences,
this is a young man in Accra who says,
"Basically, I pray concerning needs."
"What kind of needs?"
"Probably, maybe my family's going through
"a hard time, so I seek the face of God
"and I ask God to intervene."
"So do you pray for your own
emotional needs?", I say.
"I want to be rich, so I ask
God for wisdom, knowledge,
"understanding, and knowing how to be good
"to go about things, which
will promote the productivity
"and result in it."
So then, as a contrast,
this is the kind of
thing that the Americans
said to me.
"It's just like talking to a therapist.
"Especially, in the beginning..."
When talking to God.
"Especially, in the beginning
when you're revealing things
"that are deep in your
heart and deep in your soul,
"the things that have been
pushed down and denied."
Somebody else:
"You have all these thoughts,
"and they all get tangled up.
"Prayer's almost like housekeeping,
"like your room's really
messy and you're cleaning it.
"It's like you gain a perspective."
One of the things I want
to draw your attention to
in that description is
that this young woman
doesn't think that she
want to take thoughts
out of her head.
She thinks she has many
complicated, tangled thoughts.
She wants to get them
a little more orderly
so they don't arouse such anxiety in her.
The Accra Christians will talk
about this quite differently.
Evil was much more important in Accra.
When you see people in church,
this is evident.
Prayer becomes not only
a way of connecting
to God, but a weapon with
which you can fight evil.
And to give you a feel of this,
I thought I would share with you
a chunk out of my field
notes from something
called Jericho Hour.
So Jericho Hour is a three-hour event.
For Thursday mornings, nine to twelve,
every week at one of the
big Evangelical churches,
one of these new charismatics churches.
And the whole point of
the church is to break
the bounds of ancestral oppression,
and to prevent witches who might,
or evils, or demons, or
bad things in the world
that might be oppressing you,
from getting into your life.
So here are my field notes.
It's the pastor, he says,
"In the name of Jesus today,
"I declare any being,
spirit, or witchcraft
who wants to take from me my name,
I destroy in the name of Jesus today."
People are intensely speaking in tongues.
And the pastor says,
"Don't stop, don't stop.
"Pray!
"Let the Lord show you his power.
"Don't stop. Don't stop.
"Let the Lord deliver you."
And we all said together,
"In the name of Jesus, every strong enemy,
"by witchcraft, resisting, I defy by fire.
"Out, out!
"Don't stop."
And, "Out of my marriage.
"Out of our business.
"Don't stop."
And the crowd was, like,
there's 5000 people.
They're jumping up and down.
They're shaking their fists.
They're shouting this.
And, "Let the Lord deliver me
"from any strong enemy!
"By witchcraft!
"Enemies of the marriage of the house,
"of the business!
"Witches will die, die, die!"
So this doesn't happen, in my experience,
in the Vineyard.
(audience laughs)
It is true.
What's complicated about this
and sort of hard to wrap my mind around
is that evil's actually really important
in Evangelical churches
in American Christianity.
If you're going to take
the Gospel seriously,
you have to take demons seriously because
Jesus spends a lot of his
time getting rid of them.
And people will tell you
that demons are real.
But in my experience,
although, my churches
were on the edges of
university communities,
people under the Americans setting,
that evil wasn't so salient.
Where it is extremely
salient in these churches
in Accra.
In fact, people will make the argument
that the reasons that
the churches are doing
so well is that they give people tools
to fight the presence
of evil in their lives.
When I talked to the students in Accra,
they were clear that thoughts could damage
the world at a distance.
There was no, it wasn't that thoughts
were mere stuff that
passed through your mind
and was ephemeral.
Anger and envy that could
leak out of your mind
and cause people real damage.
And they could cause this damage even
if you weren't intending to cause damage.
The folks who did intend
to cause damage could
really cause a lot of damage.
So there's this model,
there's a man who says
these witches are sorcerers.
"The project in their minds.
"They could even close their minds
"and they're so powerful that thoughts
"will leave their minds and
go out and hurt somebody."
The first time I sat with
my research assistant
and said, "So what do
you do when you pray?"
She said, "I take bad
thoughts out of my mind."
As if she could sort of
physically pick them up
and take them out of her mind.
As if they were almost
physical things in the mind
that she could remove.
And the man who I quoted
at the top continues,
"I want the kind of mind
that's very positive
"and a kind of mind that's very conscious
"of God's presence, knowing
that God is beside me."
One of the things that is really striking
in these interviews is
that, not everybody,
but many, many people do
not, many people believe
that if you are a good
Christian, many people in Accra,
if you are a good Christian,
you could get envy and
anger out of your mind.
You would just pop it out.
Whereas, the Americans,
that's so antagonistic
to sort of this kind of
widely-shared Freudian model
that we have that we
are full of conflicting
negative feelings and
our challenge is learning
how to manage in the
face of our complicated,
contradictory feelings.
The Vineyard Christians
in the United States
also thought very differently
about sin in my experience.
So here is Easter morning at the Vineyard.
The associate pastor, he says,
"Shame comes when we
become aware of our own sin
"and also the sin that's done to us,
"the wrong things done to us that hurt us.
"When I feel shame, it feels
like I'm a dirty little crow
"in a room full of fancy flamingos,
"marked by whatever is dirty
and bad and worthless."
That's quite a striking image.
I feel dirty when I feel shame.
So how does the resurrection of Christ
reverse that within me and within you?
And her basic answer was,
"If you believe, it will happen.
"When I see the shame and guilt within me
"and I ask Jesus for help,
"He takes it for me and
He dies it on the cross."
That's what Jesus does.
That he needs you to
take these bad feelings
that you have inside of you
that make you feel so dirty
in a room full of fancy flamingos,
and He helps you to get rid of them.
So I was thinking about
meeting the expectations
of the Foerster lecture in
talking about immortality,
and I thought I would share
these two representations
of Heaven and the Vineyard
Christian Fellowship
in Chicago, the United
States, and in Accra.
So what Vineyard prayer
deliver the prayer towards?
When I joined the church in the South Bay,
and I joined a year-long prayer group
in which we were going to
pray systematically together
and talk about the experience of prayer.
I was given a story called
the Monk and the Samurai.
And some of you may know this story.
A samurai, a warrior, comes to a monk
and he asks the monk, "Tell
me about Heaven and Hell."
And the monk says, "You
disgusting samurai warrior.
"You just fill me with contempt.
"I can't believe you'd ask
me about this question."
The samurai's filled with rage.
He lifts up his sword to strike the monk
and the monk says, "That's Hell."
And the samurai then lowers his sword.
He feels moved and amazed
and overwhelmed with the joy
that a monk would possibly
sacrifice his life
to teach him about Heaven and Hell.
And then, the monk says, "That's Heaven."
So this was given to me
as a way of representing
what I would experience as
a result of participating
in this prayer group.
And the way that I
caricature it is by saying,
and this is not true, this is
not what the pastor would say.
But I would caricature this
by saying that Heaven and Hell
are within you, and that
if you know Jesus rightly,
your feelings would be soothed.
You would be delivered into
a state of comfort and ease
on earth today.
I don't know if this is exactly,
if this actually takes place in Accra.
But there's a scene that I
saw in these Accra churches.
This comes at the end of
a service, and a member
of the congregation, people
are holding up envelopes
filled with money and they
are marching to the front
of the sanctuary to hand over the money,
and they are seeding a miracle.
They're giving over this
money and it's going
to come back a hundredfold.
And one of my lasting memories
of going to church services,
and you can see that, it's
easy to see this on YouTube,
as well, the pastors would
prophecy over the grow,
and they'll say, "I
see 11 sets of car keys
"that are coming to people in this room.
"I see people owning their own houses.
"I see one of you owning all
the houses on your block."
And so this is often
described and is caricatured
from the American perspective
as a prosperity gospel.
Come to church, Jesus
will deliver stuff to you.
And that's certainly truly present.
I think of this, though,
as a way of more asserting
that if you go to church and
if you take Jesus seriously,
it will change who you
are in public space.
There was a sense that you were asked
in a church like this again and again
to present yourself as a choosing agent.
You choose Jesus.
You stand for Jesus.
You believe in Jesus.
And this constant choice
is what protects you
from evil, aligns you with God,
and delivers to you comfort on earth.
But it is more a social comfort.
It's a way about being
a person of authority
and stature in the world rather
than a feel-good happiness.
And, again, I'm sure the
pastors would not be comfortable
quite with the way that I framed it,
but that's what I saw
in these interactions.
You could say that these
differences have to do
with socioeconomic and
political differences
and you would absolutely be correct.
There are some very
concrete reason why people
in Accra would want money.
They don't have a lot of money.
It's a very poor city.
Even though these are
middle-class communities,
it makes sense that people want jobs.
It's also true that these are congregants
in desperate need of a
better political order.
I think when Ghana became independent,
its economic standing
per capita was on the
same level as Singapore's.
And, obviously, those
countries have diverged.
There are good reasons to feel that people
are reaching out for a
better political order.
And one very straightforward
way of explaining
the appeal of these groups
is that the traditional
African religion is a
religion which highly
valorizes and leads your
attention to the presence
of evil in the world.
One of the things that these
new charismatic churches do
is to give you the
tools to fight that evil
so you're protected and
you do not have to suffer
what other people who are
without jobs are suffering.
And that's all true.
But I also think there's
a story about the way
in which people think about their minds
and the way it shapes
their spiritual experience.
So compared to the US sample,
I thought that what I saw was that
the mind/world boundary was more porous.
That bad feelings move out of
your mind and into the world
and zap people.
I thought I saw that
feelings were the interiority
that we just celebrate and
cherish in this country.
It was just much less
salient for these students.
Unless it's envy and anger and
people are really interested
in envy and anger.
And the fantastic imagination,
walking with a great fluffy
lion by your side, just was not important
to these Accra students,
and to anything I could see in the story
of the new charismatic churches.
Imagination achieves a
practical outcome in the world
and there's a sense in the act of prayer
that words are not fluff.
They are, in some ways,
more real in the world.
Your choice of Jesus is
more real in the world
than it is in the American setting.
So just to persuade you
that there is something
about the mind that's
shaping spiritual experience
going on, I thought I
would walk you through four
of what I'm going to call
William James Experiences.
Hallucinations, the
bodily experience of God,
out of body experiences,
and sleep paralysis.
And talk to you about the
ways is which congregants
in the two different
communities talked about
these experiences when
I asked them questions.
And my comparison set here is
from some experimental work
I did in the Bay Area
where I brought 34...
I brought well over a
hundred people into my office
and randomized them to prayer
versus non-prayer practices
and saw what happened.
But before I did that, we talked to them
at considerable length about
their spiritual experience.
34 of that group came from
a Vineyard Fellowship.
And so, I'm going to
compare what they said,
what the pastoral students said,
and in the back of my mind,
I have my experience
with the Chicago Vineyard
and I also am the kind of professor
that hands out surveys and questionaires
to my undergraduates.
And so, I have a lot of little
pieces of data to compare.
So let begin by talking
about hallucinations.
It seems to me pretty
clear that the audible,
that the audible voice, hearing
a voice when you're alone,
or hearing a voice when
nobody else is present,
is more common in Accra.
At least, that's what
the evidence suggests.
So when I sat with people
in the United States
and said, "Have you ever
heard God speak audibly?"
You know, roughly a seventh
of our Vineyard sample
said yes.
Six out of 15 folks in Accra said yes.
Not only that but three our
of 15 said that they heard
God's voice audibly several times a week.
That's pretty unusual.
They were not psychotic.
They were more willing
to describe themselves
as having this hallucinatory experience.
I gave people pen and paper,
I gave people surveys,
questionaires to fill out and,
in my class, or my Daniel Institute folks.
60% of them said that they
had heard a voice when alone.
50% of my US sample did.
I give these questionaires
to undergraduates.
Even more striking
difference because I had
my research assistant go
into the University of Legon,
and hand out questionaires.
Many more people willing to say that they
has heard an audible voice.
I gave people a different
kind of questionaire
that asks in many different kinds of ways
about whether they've had
unusual auditory experiences.
Much more likely to be the case in Accra
that people say yes.
And I wanted to share with you a snippet
of one of my interviews.
This was with a young
woman and we're talking
about hearing God speak.
"Have you ever heard God speaks in a way
"that you can hear with your ears?"
"Yes." she said.
"Yes, many times it's
his word confirmed to me.
"I hear somebody say the word in my ears."
So, you know, here's your
perseverative anthropologist.
"Okay, how commonly does it feel
"that that's actually auditory?
"So that you would hear
it with your ears?"
And she does something very interesting.
She says, "As soon as
I'm conscious of it."
And so, I leap in, assuming
this is like the way
Americans talk.
"It stops?"
And she says, "No, as soon
as I'm conscious of it.
"When I'm conscious that
I'm hearing God speak,
"I hear it."
And then, I say, "Oh, then
it pops out and becomes
"more auditory?"
And she says, "Yes."
So these unusual sensory
experiences are really interesting.
I cannot say to any of you,
hear God speak audibly.
But I can invite you
to have an experience.
I can invite you to pay attention
to your unusual sensory experience.
You know, after a while,
over the next six months,
a couple of you, maybe five or six,
will have some kind of odd auditory
hearing-voice experience.
There's something that's
involved in learning
and the way that people come
to report these experiences.
And there seems to be more
willingness to pay attention
to them and to report
them in my Accra group.
Bodily experience of prayer.
So these of three kinds
of phenomena that often
travel together.
People are overwhelmed by emotion.
They start praying.
They start crying, crying, crying.
They can't stop.
Or they feel really, really weak
and they have to sit down.
Or they feel like there's
an adrenalin rush.
And sometimes people do more of the crying
and sometimes people
do more of the shaking.
But there are things
that you see happening
in a congregation.
So the Americans like to do this stuff
in a church like the Vineyard.
They love to do it in Accra.
So it was visibly
evident to me that people
did more of this bodily
experience of God stuff
in these congregations
in which I saw thousands
of people worshiping God.
In Accra, it was clearly
evident in the interviews
that people liked doing this stuff.
And what I found really striking, also,
was that the more people talked about,
the more people talked
about loving to experience
God in their body, the more they reported
a vivid back and forth
imaginal dialogue with God.
And that relation did not hold up,
that was not true in my American sample.
There's something much more physical
about the experience of God in Accra.
Out of body experience.
So, technically, these
are they experiences
that you can generate by
just stimulating the brain
when somebody is on a laboratory table.
These are experiences when
people feel themselves
not in their body, and
sometimes they turn around
and they see themselves.
So none of you has probably
had one of these experiences.
We don't know exactly how common they are
in the general population.
But it was really clear
that there was a different
degree of interest in
having those experiences
among the Accra students
and the Vineyard group.
So with my Americans,
the idea that your mind
should leave your body and
that you could turn around
and look at yourself, my
Americans thought that
was a totally neat idea.
40% of them said that they'd
had an experience like that.
That's pretty unlikely.
But looking at what they aid,
maybe 20% had an experience
that was like an out of body experience.
My Accra students were
horrified by the idea.
Only one of them said that
they'd had such an experience
and, to her, it was a
sign that she was dying.
And, in fact, ethnographically,
leaving your body
is associated with death in this world.
Sleep paralysis.
Being awake but unable to move.
So this is an event in the world.
Roughly a quarter of Americans
report this experience
at some point.
These are these moments when you wake up.
It's the middle of the night.
Typically, you're sleeping on your back.
And you can't move.
It's pretty freaky.
You feel as if there's a
heavy weight on your chest.
Often, there's something
clutching your throat.
And, often, you feel as if
there's an evil presence
in the room.
These experience are reported
in at least 30 cultures.
We know they're out there.
About a third of the
Americans in my little sample
reported that they'd
had such an experience.
Again, it's about the American rate.
And half of them dismissed it.
"Yeah, but I was overtired.
"It was kind of trippy but it
wasn't anything spiritual."
If the American identified
it as the presence
of a demon, then the American went on
at much greater length and
they would talk about it.
Accra, over two-thirds of the sample
report sleep paralysis.
And this is, and there a
couple of other sources
of data that will support this.
And they talk about it at length.
So here's a man who says,
"I laid down one night.
"I felt a heavy presence in the room.
"It was so heavy and it fell on me..."
This is a woman, actually.
"The thing held my next down
and held by belly button
"like that.
"The think was like this.
"And I felt the finger of the thing
"and it was pressing me down.
"As such, the room became heavy.
"I said, 'Jesus, Jesus, Jesus!',
"and it just lifted."
So this is one of the shorter examples
because the others
wouldn't fit on the page.
So I think that there's a story here.
I think there's a story
about a different theory
of mine, and by this, I
mean a local set of ideas
about how the mind is
constituted and whether
it's separate from the world,
and whether thoughts are real in the world
the way the tables and chair are real.
And I think that helps to
explain these phenomena.
So I think the fact that there is this,
the mind/world boundary's more porous
and anger and envy can
leak out and cause damage.
I think that helps to
explain the fact that
an adult's mind in Accra, I think,
is more connected to the body.
So the idea of losing the mind and having
the mind separate from the body, I think,
is just freakily scary
to these Accra students
in a way that is not to Americans
who were totally happy with
the idea that their mind
can go zipping around and going
hunting on the astral plane
or doing whatever else.
Americans, they really
talk about their feelings.
In Accra, it makes sense
that the bodily experience
of God is so much more
important because the body,
in some sense, counts
more than the feelings.
There's something that makes sense
about the sense of evil
being more important,
more salient, and feeling the evil more in
your body and maybe reporting
more sleep paralysis experiences.
And I think that
hallucinations are more common
because there's more...
I think the people are
less committed to this idea
of a radical boundary between
the mind and the world.
They're also a little bit
more committed to the sense
that the words are somehow
real in the world and maybe
they have their own own realness.
In any event, I think there's a story here
about the anthropology
of mind and imagination
that I know Charles Hirschkind and others
on this campus are
involved when I see them
as part of this general project.
My goal is to identify dimensions
of this cultural phenomenon
which is the local
theory of mind, the way
in which you could think
about the structure of your mind.
And I think there are real
psychological consquences
from these different ideas about the mind.
And the way I frame this,
or the way I'm seeking
to frame this is in terms of social
or cultural kindling.
So we know that psychiatric
illness, for example,
varies according to the
way that this culture
imagines psychiatric symptoms.
It also varies according
to whether you have had
an experience before, you're
more likely to have it again.
So the classic example, where
the term social kindling
actually rises from, is depression.
The first time that
somebody has an experience
of major depressive disorder,
chances are something lousy
has happened in their life.
They've gotten divorced.
They've lost a job.
Something really bad has happened.
It doesn't take as much
blow for that person
to develop major depressive
disorder the next time.
It's as if the pathways
in their neural pathways
are more tightly connected so there's more
of an invitation to respond again,
the way you respond the first time.
And psychiatric
anthropologists have been able
to demonstrate that there are different
patterns in the way that
people, for example,
feel depression in their body.
Maybe people are more
likely to feel joint pain
rather than sadness.
I think that the story
of spiritual experience
is going to come out in
a similar kind of way.
That the way that we think
about about our minds
will shape the way that we pay attention
to mental events.
And that the way that we
attend to these events
will change the way we experience them
and that there will be
sort of a cascade effect
in which people are more likely to report
these powerful unusual experiences
in ways that are shaped
by their expectations
about the mind.
So let me leave it there.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)